on the surface level uh devices uh our
phones are distracting us from a lot of
things that really matter being forced
to not be around my phone for so
long was so amazing and allowed me to
ponder life and also be open to people
when I did come in contact with them
that was a really big thing you know I
think we put up a lot of walls and we
have a lot of labels for different types
of people and different people in
regions of the country and stuff and we
get all of that those these assumptions
about each other based on updates on our
phone and having to put that down and
interact with others I found that people
were extremely beautiful and awe
inspiring and just interesting just the
random like guyan overalls in Missouri
just blow your mind with the stuff that
they have to say